As well as being one of Madrid's most popular meeting spots,...
...the Puerta Del Sol or Gateway of the Sun...
...is also a point from which the main road distances in Spain are measured...
...and six of its national highways technically start here.
So, "galleta" is Spanish for cookie or biscuit.
But unless I figure out where to buy them, that information is useless.
The ladies are actually an order of nuns known as the Carboneras,...
...after the coal bunker in which the convent's portrait of the Virgin Mary was found.
But they're probably better known for selling their homemade goodies,...
...which the Carboneras have done since the 17th century.
The nuns belong to a closed order,...
...which means they've taken a strict vow of isolation.
So, how do you sell cookies and stay out of sight?
Piece of cake.
Madrid's wrought iron Atocha train station to the south of the city is over 100 years old.
But the garden didn't make an appearance until the 1980s.
The much needed overhaul was part of a wave of growth and rejuvenation...
...that followed nearly four decades of General Franco's right-wing dictatorship.
Originally created exclusively for royalty and high society,...
...Madrid's huge and beautiful Parque del Retiro later relaxed the rules to include anyone in proper attire.
These days, anything goes...
...so everyone can enjoy its lush greenery,...
...open spaces or the cool waters of the artificial lake...
...in front of Alfonso XII's impressive mausoleum.